Your textbook looks like a rainbow threw
up on it and somehow you think that's
studying. The research is absolutely
shocking. Highlighting doesn't just fail
to help your memory. It actually makes
retention worse. You forget 50% of new
information within 1 hour. Half of
everything you just studied vanishes
before you finish your coffee. But
here's the good news. Your brain isn't
broken. Your methods are. Stop feeding
your brain. Make it hunt for food. Close
your book and write down everything you
remember. You'll feel stupid at first.
That feeling means it's working. The
science proves this works. Students who
use active recall retain 50% more
information than those who just reread
material. Your brain loves surprises.
Review after one day, then 3 days, then
one week. Each review should happen just
as you're about to forget. The future
belongs to learners. And now you know
how to learn.